is it refreshing to play a woman whether
it's just like there is nothing
whatsoever around kind of her looks this
is very much just about her yeah who she
is yeah that's part of the reason why I
wanted her hair gone as well
um I think we have this awful nature
well I do sometimes that when things are
going wrong I just like chop bits of
myself off
um and that idea actually came from me
when I was younger I was just going
through that classic teenage bout of
depression where you're not quite sure
that you're depressed so I just bought
random things and tried to quick fix
myself like just buy things that would
stick on me and maybe I'd feel better
and so that was an idea that I was
saying well what if she just chops off
piece of her for no reason other than
just trying to fix something and then
what that did is it made this whole
character not care anymore
um and have hair that is ridiculous
um and I loved that I loved I always
loved stepping into a role where I don't
have to care about being
being camera beauty or anything like
that I love not
not being able to have to think about
that and that was just a perfect example
of cool came to work had my hair combed
a bit and off I go you know it was
really lovely